i've got to get to gay cookies before we
go i have to
i want to i want to end where we began
on democrats weird sex obsession
oreos beginning october 9th
are shipping out rainbow-colored cookies
colored cream cookies that are given
away to the first 10 000 people
to share on social media their idea of
allyship
allyship is some newfangled word that
refers to
endorsing the sexual revolution
endorsing the left's view on sex
specifically they say it's with regard
it used to be with regard to
homosexuality now it's obviously
expanded much more than that to the lgbt
which is kind of
the t undermines the g right because the
transgender undermines
the arguments for same same-sex
attraction or the homosexual orientation
because the t
undermines your gender so you know just
to put it in simple terms
if you're a gay guy and you say oh i
can't change this i was born this way
and then you got the transgender
movement comes along and says of course
you can change your gender so then the
gay guy
makes himself cosmetically look like a
woman i guess he's no longer a gay guy
so i guess he did change his sexual
orientation
or he didn't change his gender
or gender is a silly concept pushed by
the left and really there's biological
sex which obviously you can't change
either way this is an ideology this is
not
a sexual preference or a sexual
orientation or whatever words you want
to use
this is left wing ideology
and it's even come into our cookies
cookies
how did we get here the the democrat
obsession with sex the left's obsession
with sex
it's not about guys who are sexually
attracted to other guys
or gals or sexually attracted other gals
or people who are confused about their
sex or have some kind of psychological
issue not about that at all
not about that at all it is about
control
this derives from a simple phrase that
the feminist left gave us in the 19 late
1960s early 1970s
the personal is the political
the personal is the political that
basically politics has to come down
to every thing in our society has to
enter into the bedroom has to enter
into the local community has to enter
into our sneakers has to enter into our
food
has to enter into our chicken sandwiches
has to enter into our cookies everything
has to be political
but there is a flip side to this which
is as everything becomes political
the only thing that gets de-politicized
is politics
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you